家庭边的司法解释2，最近确实影响力太大了。客观的讲，这个司法解释它就该有这么大的影响力，因为它影响的是千千万万个普通的家庭，它影响的是千千万万个男男女女。它不光影响女性，也影响男性。不管是你作为女性，作为男性婚姻家庭编的这个司法解释2，不管你要不要走入婚姻。
哪怕你不走入婚姻，你就是同居这个婚姻家庭面的司法解释2，你也得学。因为这里面不光是规定了结婚之后的一些权利义务或者财产的问题，它还规定了一些没有结婚你就是谈恋爱，就是同居在一起的权利义务和一些财产的问题。我们接下来就正式开始给大家讲婚姻家庭间的司法解释2，因为婚姻家庭编的司法解释二，已经在2025年的2月1号正式的生效了，就是他已经是开始影响我们千千万万的呃老百姓了。那这个婚姻家庭编的司法解释二，它总共呢，就二十几条，总共是4000多个字。它其实跟我们民法典中的婚姻家庭编，我们民法典中的婚姻家庭边是五十几条，也是4000多个字儿加起来字儿都不多，但是它着实对我们实实在在的每一个人都会产生深远的影响。我们就逐条来跟大家讲解。我们先来看第一条，这条是说重婚的这种情况啊，重婚是什么呢？就是他第一把的婚姻是合法的，他还没离。
然后他就跟第二把的人呢，就办了另外一个结婚证，或者跟第二把这个人呢，以夫妻的名义注意啊，以夫妻的名义生活在一起，长期稳定的生活在一起。这个呢，叫重婚。那有的人就认为啊，我的第二把这个关系可不可以基于你第一把的这个婚姻关系，你俩离了，或者第一把的这个婚姻关系，哎哟，去世了，那我第二把的这个婚姻关系，可不可以自动升级为一个有效的婚姻，升级为一个合法的婚姻呢？不可以。
你第二把这个关系是重婚，从他一开始他就是一个违法的行为，从他一开始就是一个无效的行为。所以第二把的这个重婚的关系不会因为第一把的婚姻关系当中，人家离婚了也好，人家去世了也好，不会因为这个自动升级为一个有效的婚姻关系。这一款他讲的那个话，我跟大家念一下啊，就是当事人依据民法典第1051条第一项的请求，确认重婚的婚姻无效。那提起诉讼的时候，合法的婚姻当事人已经离婚或者配偶已经死亡，被告以此为抗辩后遗，婚姻自以上情形发生时转为有效的，人民法院不予支持。好，这个就是司法解释。这个司法解释对大家来说的话，理解起来可能比较困难，那龙飞姐刚刚讲的那个呢，是用老百姓能够听得懂的话给大家讲了一遍，翻译了一遍，无效就是自始都是无效的，从一开始就是无效的。那这对于第二把这个关系，它分割财产就会非常影响非常的大。那第二把关系，你无论怎样，你都是无效的，那么就不存在夫妻共同财产的概念。第二把的这个重婚，你说重婚的配偶，你想要分对方的这个财产，想要分说他挣了多少钱。你说我俩也办个结婚证啊，我俩也办了酒席啊，我俩也。
也一起生孩子了呀，我俩也在一起共同生活呀，我俩是什么实际的这个婚姻啊，都没有用啊。第二把的这个重婚关系在分财产的时候，他是按照无效的婚姻关系去分财产的，就这么个意思啊。那有个朋友感觉这个不是个问题啊，再去登记就行了吧。你的意思是第二把的这个重婚的这个人再去登记就行了是吗？但如果第二把这个人他想要去登记的话，得等前面那一把离了婚，得等前面那一把呃去世，那么第二把这个人才有这个机会去重新登记。那第二把这个人去登记的时候，你们的婚姻关系是从什么时候开始算？是从你们真正符合了前面那个离婚了，前面那个去世了，然后你去登记。从你登记那个时候开始算婚姻关系。那那个时候的话，夫妻的共同财产的起算节点是不一样的。
你有可能跟他都生活10年了，那么这10年可能是无效的婚姻。人家前头那个离婚了，或者前头那个去世了，然后你重新去跟他登记，那是10年之后的事儿了。就是他在第一段婚姻还没有结束的时候去进行第二段婚姻。这个第二段婚姻他就是违法的，就是无效的，就这么简单的逻辑啊。第二条讲的是什么呢，第二条，简单粗暴好理解，就是说，你们两口子甭管是因为什么原因去民政局办了离婚证，管你是因为买房也好，因为逃债也好，因为孩子上学也好，因为保谁的工作也好，因为干什么也好，不重要。你们两口子只要是正儿八经去民政局领了那张离婚证了，那么你们的夫妻关系就已经定了，就是已经那个解除了。
啊，然后有很多人是不是说哎呀，我俩实际上当时是为了买房，我俩去领了一张离婚证，但我俩还在一起过呀，我俩还在一起养啊，甚至我俩还生了一个孩子呀，我俩还生三胎了呀。在这种情况下，如果将来人家不想跟你过了，那人家撂腿就跑，拎腿就跑，你去打官司，你说法官大人，我俩是属于假离婚，我俩其实啊还在一起生了三胎啊，我俩这个婚姻关系能不能恢复？请问能恢复吗？各位明确告诉大家啊，离了就是离了，甭管你俩因为什么原因，因为什么理由，你俩去办了这个离婚证了。你俩这关系，只要人家不同意，你就恢复不了。但是如果说你手上有足够的证据来证明你是受到了欺诈，那么，分割财产的这方面有没有可能你再争取自己去重新打一个官司，重新分割这个财产呢？这个是有可能的。比如你有另外签的这个财产协议，比如你有录音，比如你有聊天记录，能够证明当时你俩去呃办那个离婚证的时候，分割财产的那个协议不是你俩的真实意愿，你俩其实还有另外一个真实的约定，有一个真实的这个意愿，那这种情况下可能。
能财产这个事儿，你还有呃打个官司重新分的机会，但是身份就你俩呃解除了夫妻关系，身份这事儿是没有回头路可以走的，只要人家不想跟你过了，那你这个关系就恢复不了了。那讲这个法条讲这个司法解释啊，希望大家能注意是什么呢？就是不管你老婆或者你老公，现在以什么理由忽悠你去办那个离婚证的时候，你要把它当成真的去分财产。你要把它当成真的，你俩是离了之后回不去的情况下分财产。你至少说在财产上，你不要成为那种就像电视上演的啊，说为了逃债，然后分财产的时候怎么怎么地的啊，或者为了买房，为了买新的房子，忽悠你要给你买一套新的房子。然后，这一把离婚的时候就把房子给了他了。然后你就净身出户了。你净身出户了，你还等着说我们两口子一起买一套新的房子呢。结果人家不想跟你过了，人家分到财产，人家就跑了。怕的是这个，刚刚有个朋友说分居两年以上比较容易离嘛，你别想那个现实生活中啊，如果你已经想好了要跟他分开，你就不要等分居两年了之后再去跟他分开。原因是什么啊？就是分居两年，它是一个法律上很难证明的东西。
东西，而且法律上他不光要求你是分居两年，他要求你是因为感情不和分居两年，然后你再去起诉是吧。但是，你你怎么证明是因为感情不和呢？拿什么东西能证明你是因为感情不和呢？再有一个分居两年，你怎么才能证明你跟他分居两年了呢？你们有没有看过以前有一个非常著名的卖书的网站的两口子，他俩两口子打那个离婚官司的时候，你想要证明感情破裂都挺难的人家中秋节了，给你送点粽子，或者说人家过什么节了，给你发个问候啊。又约着一起吃个饭，约着一起带孩子看个电影。所以，大家如果说你想明白了，要跟他分开的话，你不要等，不要等分居两年了再去起诉。你就当时当下，你拎包走人了，你就分居，你就去起诉，这样的话，对于你来说是时间成本可能更低的，就这个意思啊，第三条讲的是就是那种想要通过。
离婚来逃避债务的行为，这个是行不通的原因是什么呢？第三条讲了，就这夫妻一方的债权人注意啊，这个债务它一定是其中一方的债务，它不是两口子共同的债务。也就是说，欠钱这个人，他有可能结婚之前欠的钱，有可能他结婚之后虽然欠的这个钱吧，这个钱他没有用到家庭的夫妻共同生活当中，没有用到夫妻共同经营当中，是他个人欠的债。如果说是两口子共同欠的债，那你们两口子离婚这事儿一点用都没有。原因是什么？原因是作为债权人，他直接把你们两口子共同当成被告去起诉就完事儿了。所以，你们两口子离婚怎么分财产，一点都不影响人家债权人去主张你们两口子共同还钱这个事儿。
但如果说这个债是一方的债，夫妻一方或者是在婚前欠的，或者是在婚后欠的，但绝不可能是在你俩离完婚之后再欠的债。因为你俩离完婚之后，他再欠的债跟你一点关系都没有。这个债他是个人的债，他是婚姻关系存续之前离婚之前欠的债。这几个点给大家界定好了。在这种情况下，如果债权人发现哟，你们两口子在离婚的时候，比如说张三，欠我100万。
张三在离婚的时候，把房子、车子、存款全都给他媳妇儿了。在这种情况下，我作为债权人，我就拥有了一项权利。什么权利呢？我可以去撤销你们两口子关于财产分配的条款。
但你们两口子离婚这事儿，我撤销不了，因为我是个外人。你们两口子离婚天我老子也撤撤销不了啊。这是你们的身份关系，你们两口子说孩子归谁这事儿，这我也管不了。孩子归谁是你们两口子的事儿。好，你们两口子哪些条款我有可能申请去撤销呢？就是当我发现你欠我100万，完了之后，你90%的钱，80%的钱都给你媳妇儿了，或者都换成抚养费了。这种情况下，你就没钱还我了呀，你就从这段婚姻里面出来了之后，你就是个光棍儿。你没钱还我了，那我作为债权人，我就可以向法院去提起一个诉讼，撤销你们之间的财产分配的条款。所以，那些想要通过离婚来逃避债务的行为，这个挺难的，法官在收到你的这个撤销之诉的请求之后，法官他也得看一下看一下他俩离婚的时候分的这个财产合不合情理，合不合法律。那怎么来看呢？就他俩在离婚的时候啊，看看谁有过错呀，对孩子这个抚养费大概是个什么水平啊，财产分配大概是个什么比例啊？如果法官一看就他俩这个财产的分配，比如说是55%，对45%，其中那个45%的是出轨方，是过错方，那法官可能就会觉得。
这个分配是合理的，分配是合理的，法官就会觉得，那你作为债权人，你只能问欠你债的张三去要钱，人家这个分配是合理的。但反过来讲，如果法官发现哟，这张三把所有的钱，房子、车子存款所有的钱都给他媳妇儿了，或者这个张三有一套房，这套房价值100万，直接把这套房抵作了孩子的抚养费了。那在这种情况下，法官可能就会觉得一眼能看出来，你这显然是为了逃避债务，显然是不太符合我们日常看到的夫妻财产分配的这样一个常理。那在这种情况下，就有可能支持债权人的申请，撤销掉他们夫妻离婚的时候分财产这个条款，一条主要它保护的是什么，主要保护的是债权人的利益，那主要防范的是什么？主要防范的是那种故意离婚逃债的行为，给大家讲明白了啊。